In this lesson, we learned how
treating your screen as a shared stage
that elements purposely move in and out
of makes your UI more understandable.
>> We studied how animation can
explain complex state changes and
make the user feel in control.
>> We considered what makes
a good transition and
how to apply this to
the elements in your UI.
>> And finally, we looked at how motion
can provide elements of delight and
whimsy that express
the personality of your app.
>> Stay with us for the next lesson,
where we'll study how to apply
everything we've learned so far to
the myriad of devices out there through
something we call adaptive design.